哈喽大家好
我是CINDY王心凌
如果你喜欢本集的节目的话
别忘了一键三连
隆重给朋友
有这么美的老板
就是笑嘻嘻的上班
王心凌老师还跟我对眼
看了一下我
谁可以比他甜呐
啊哈哈
众所周知啊
like music团队呢
在各大演唱会中也是久经沙场的纪录片常客了
今天呢也很有幸啊
在王心凌团队的邀约下
我们来到了王心凌
舒格海2.0广州站演唱会的现场
不过今天这期视频呀在记录之余呢
稍微有那么一点点不一样
我们还做了一个小挑战
小挑战对挑战
那我们就成立了一个摄影特种小分队啊
大家呢带着大家自己擅长的设备
一起走进王心凌SUGHAI的22.0演唱会
广州场的台前和幕后
Lets go
和姐妹草约会
♪ Say ok ♪
通常来说呢一场演唱会的记录啊
我们会出动至少五位摄影师
从彩排日开始拍摄
直到演出结束期间呢
会对大量团队的主创
包括艺人本人进行采访
了解他们的创作思路和工作幕后
并且呢会去到那些大家去不到的角落
近距离的帮大家拍摄
整个演唱会的精密机关装置和舞台上下的设备
每位摄影呢将各司其职啊
观众朋友们也可以给他们所拍的画面打分
0~10分打在弹幕上
彭程老师今天什么任务干碎其他所有人
我在这里可以直接拉到
王心凌老师的脸的大特写
我肤色好
硕大的肌肉
嘿8K肉red
迅猛龙电影机啊
我肤色好
我一个人掌控三颗镜头
你行吗
玩的明白吗
你拍的明白吗
我肤色我可以同时拍两个机位
没有时间跟你们这群韭菜扯淡
我要赶紧去工作了
我要赶紧去拍我们的王心凌老师了
再见呼
在跑1.0的过程
就觉得好像观众到了现场就好像进入一个乐园
所以我们很想要把2.0就打造成一个乐园
包含是整个舞台设计
就要给大家有一个印象
就是sugar就是糖果
所以我们的其实舞台造型它是一个糖果造型
特地找了陈奕仁导演
他很会做一些电脑的3D动画
所以就是想要打造一个超现实
从演唱会的一开始
就带观众进入到另外一个空间里面去
♪ 王森林 ♪
我们一样要用我们最真诚的热情
跟我们最真诚的笑
把这个真诚的这个热情的感觉带给广州
所有的观众
好不好
好
广州徐州
广州嘿
广州苏州徐州嘿
我在王心凌老师的这个休息室啊
和以及他的舞蹈团队的这个排练室啊
拍到了一些王心凌与他的团队
沟通和庆祝的一些画面哦
第一视角能拍到一些非常及时性的东西
对
而且王心凌老师还跟我对眼看了一下
我估计哇好幸福啊
对我估计他应该是看到我脸上的贴纸了
兄弟们刀了他
那最难的就是要去说服所有的舞者跟那个艺人
最帅的出场是这个方
那要是大家不能接受的话
我们有一个big plan
扶着就从地上出来
但我觉得大家知道这个效果的时候
大家其实都会激发自己的肾上腺素
我一定要达成
是第一次上去的时候
大家都很害怕
但是都很安全
所以就是后来就也克服了这样子
因为我们从天而降
我觉得我自己很像女神
不要管我
因为安全的考量一定是第一嘛
那那我们第一个先有把握去解决
而且他有去帮忙安抚舞者
说在他站在那个神像第一次要上去的时候
他有跟大家先喊话一下
他知道安全一定没问题
那剩下都要靠我们
♪ 我还在这一切外起风 ♪
♪ 把我听到全世界 ♪
♪ 开始游戏 ♪
♪ 到时坚强出击 ♪
广州的朋友
红楼梦金
大家好
我是今天SUGAY的CEOCI王心凌
嗯我觉得机关来说是真的蛮困难的
我在天上掉下来的那个鱼钓台
其实他分成两层
然后20一个人
然后本身那个吊台的重量
然后跟各个场馆额的一些结构的不同
只要一个地方卡住
就会所有机关都停下来
呃
这个它升起来就是层层叠叠的那个蛋糕
那个形状
所以我们把它命名为蛋糕升降
升降台立面是有那种银流苏配合灯光设计
然后还有激光
它会有很炫的那种感觉
然后这边我们三个呢就是属于A升降
这里属于B升降
这一组呢他可以升得比A声线更高
面对观众测呢是有装立面屏幕的
然后LD画面会和两侧的屏幕
还有后后面的屏幕组成
哇这个太复杂了
这个啊
♪ 深海是个海 ♪
♪ 甜甜的 ♪
♪ 跑得快 ♪
♪ 对不起 ♪
♪ 你也快 ♪
♪ 哎呀是海是海 ♪
♪ 你在缺铁缺钙 ♪
♪ 我觉得是去的海 ♪
走进演唱会的现场舞美啊
不愧是获得了缪斯设计奖的舞台
舞台呢整体效果呀甜度爆表
而且呢搭配多层结构的机械装置呀
可以变换出多种舞台效果
搭配360度的天幕环境啊
以及曲面屏幕
可以让整个舞美看起来更加的立体
刚开始前置的作业的时候
就有拿到整个舞美的模型
那我们针对这个模型去做拆解
在设计呃动画视觉效果的时候
我们有一个很正确的模拟
每个观众的角度的画面
每一个观众的角度
我们在事前的模拟当中都有去构思到
照顾到每一个啊观众所眼睛所看到的视觉效果
整体的整个动态视觉效果里面
都为了这一个舞美的这个舞台设计的造型下去
相应而生
所有的动画视觉内容
♪ 天明天都有工作 ♪
♪ 爱上班门的太空梭 ♪
♪ 来自海上全宇宙 ♪
♪ 就在今晚要睡个嗨嗨 ♪
那这个镭射的应用
对于整个演出的这个氛围有什么帮助呢
而我觉得他比较能够直接的
跟观众有一个很好的一个互动
会让空间感变强哦
那给我们演示一下
然后我们把它设计完了之后
他大概就会长
我靠哇
这个效果好明显啊对啊
对我这里扫不到吧
不不不
安全安全安全安全
然后据说这次还有一个云海的那个镭射
对
对它的效果会长这个样
因为每一个场地可能多多少少会有点不一样
譬如说像有一些艺人站的特殊的
比较特殊一点的位置
然后跟一些特殊的效果
我可能抓了之后交易主灯出来
然后我就可以随时抓到我想要的位置
因为这些东西都是我们会先自动
我都我们都会先编排好的
然后等于说一首一首歌做调整
这样
然后我在其实在后台拍到了非常多
工作人员工作的画面
演唱会嘛并不是一个艺人就能完全完成
其实他的幕后有非常非常多的工作人员
比较让我震撼的呢是今天舞台上的所有装置
全部都是人推上去的
人推上或屏幕
这个你拍到了
我拍到了
我也看到了
音响老师以及技师老师就在旁边待命
去调整设备的画面
那我这台red8K摄影机呢
因为它整个的画质呢是比较高清啊
在霸总的阵营里应该也不算差吧
我用这台摄影机呢捕捉到了很多细节性的东西
比如说呢我捕捉到了很多
王心凌老师各种状态下的一个特写
♪ Just you and i in paradise ♪
♪ She got me feeling like ♪
♪ I'm on a shirt at high ♪
♪ 熬成天然零添加的 ♪
♪ Let trp high baby ♪
♪ I am really like i'm on a sh ♪
♪ 跟H爱是你打开这一片海 ♪
舞台上的表演越精彩
幕后的准备工作呢就越紧张
穿过坐落在舞台角落的秘密通道
我们跟着工作人员呢来到了舞台下
看到了后台真实的忙碌场景
所以你会看到里面有很多机械哇
真正的幕后英雄都在这个位置哦
辛苦的一体同仁对
所以说大家一定要关注每一场演唱会
其实在背后有非常多工作人员
辛辛苦苦的在为大家呀
为所有的演唱会的正常举办
付出了非常多的汗水和努力啊
大家给他们点个赞
点个三连可以吧
对当然还有艺人的环节
对像艺人
他其实有一些快速换装的桥段
他可能就要下来
很快速的进来
可能几十秒就要再上去了
同时间有六七个人要用头发
用衣服不用装
好像那个赛车进场换轮胎
换完就走这样
但这个过道还是挺宽敞的
对啊
不然不够
因为我们太多了
而且还有一个备用的
第二个是他如果要从另外一边
他也可以从这里装
而且我看您的团队有很多很多的年轻人哈
那您在整个的训练过程中
对他们有什么样的一个期许
但其实他们也都是资历蛮深的
就是包含我们的舞者
他们其实也都是啊
在自己这个舞蹈领域都是老师级的
的确想要给他们点空间
所以我们在有1part那个让乐手啊
让舞者们就是能够表现自己的那一派
至少我不希望那1part
就是只是为了让我下台去换衣服
我希望那1part也可以像一个节目
其实也有看到我在台下
有听到有些歌迷朋友看到他们的努力
然后会给予很多掌声跟尖叫
其实我也很替他们开心
也感到骄傲
♪ Boy girls ♪
因为我是新加入的忙内
我是年纪最小的对
所以难免大家可能跟他工作时间比较长
但我应该只有跟他工作快满一年
所以相对起来还是会有点紧张
那在整个的整个舞蹈过程中
您最喜欢哪首歌或者哪个章节的编配呢
你这样问一定是海鸥啊
海鸥对吧
为什么
因为有那个最开心的互动
最开心的互动
我不能讲太开心
因为我怕太开心了会不开心
对对我开心对对
大家不开心啊哈哈
♪ 谁搞不清楚谁是谁 ♪
♪ 放弃了 ♪
♪ 看世界不能用格 ♪
给我辈子还给我
♪ 突然出1so厨 ♪
♪ 一场无际的雨 ♪
♪ 我掉进海里 ♪
♪ 深海里 ♪
♪ 你看来的全世界大地 ♪
♪ 我在那么远 ♪
♪ 就需要去回掉 ♪
♪ 你说我下一次要继续找海幸福秘籍 ♪
♪ 欢迎来新y party ♪
♪ Cindy cindy cindy ♪
让你伤心
怎么可以CICD又快递
主要的话我担任的是first keyboard的角色
最主要的一定会先有电钢琴的音色
然后上面的那台琴会是合成器
所以两个音色会结合在一起
变成复合式的音色
那当然我们还有融合一些复古的元素
希望让他听起来比较MARIN一点
所以啊这个在使用上我们都是经过了一些协调
但是乐队的合作上是蛮快就进入状况
然后我们发现这次在您的乐队里面
有一位女鼓手
她她打鼓非常的有牌
她以前呃在跟其他的歌手合作的时候
他在跟电脑编程
它是可以咬非常紧的
然后又可以有自己的呼吸
我觉得这样的鼓手很特别对
所以我才邀请他过来加入你
你有两套准备两套鼓对吧
哎这次这两套鼓分别是有什么呃用处吗
两套鼓的那个音色上是不一样的
对那在摇滚的部分呢
他的声音就是会比较啊有一种粗犷的感觉
主要那一套鼓呢就是比较精致
然后细的呃小东西也比较多
这样子你觉得哪一个哪个part
你觉得是希望大家最集中注意力来听
我觉得应该是想啊
睫毛弯弯啊
劈你的雷啊
这些嗯我觉得都很不错
兴奋快下跳
♪ 灵魂快要出窍 ♪
♪ 这感觉真好 ♪
♪ 有你对着我微笑 ♪
温度越来越高
♪ 怎么办才好 ♪
♪ 眼神的烦恼 ♪
♪ 小鹿在乱跳的心扉 ♪
♪ 心情荡秋千 ♪
♪ 脸像红苹果 ♪
♪ 草莓种甜美BB ♪
♪ 你是谁 ♪
为什么呃
有一首歌叫睫毛弯弯啊
对那个这次就变成有点国风
里面是扇子舞
然后做了很多舞台的效果
我发现那个睫毛弯弯的舞台有很多的中国元素
比如说有扇子
那个VJ也变成了那个孔雀
对皮肤都有换
嘿嘿大家来看心灵演唱会呢
一定会听到很多千禧年出奇的金曲啊
不管是编曲还是编舞
很多歌曲呢都给予了改编
在致敬经典的同时啊
还增加了很多属于这个时代的创新
那结合心灵稳定的唱功
精彩的表演
绚丽的舞美观感特别出色
音响部分啊
整场采用了法国顶级的音响品牌
l cos stx k系列
并且呢采用了KS28补充低频
通过CARA呢来补充了更多位置的声音点位
可以让声音呢更好的覆盖到整场
整场音响呢用了120只左右哈
整套音响系统呢造价不菲
更重要的是我们看到了心灵
非常重视视听效果啊
而且他能记得住很多麦克风振膜的型号
而且一个个去试哈
以适配不同的场馆
对声音的要求呢非常用心且苛刻
一切也都为了大家能得到一个最好的视听感受
在每一场的那个声音效果
他很在意
因为对声音的要求
所以他会自己很专注在研究所有麦克风的型号
所以他可以背出很多不同麦克风型号的声音
效果不一
然后秦老师我听说就是很多的
就比如说台下的monitor
还有pa老师说您对音频这一块就特要求特别高
对我好像对这个部分就是蛮认真的去了解
因为我觉得每一个麦克风的音头
都会有不同的特性
有些比较嘈杂的环境声音
很多时候肯定要用这个音头
有些比较安静的环境
可能可以再用灵敏一点的音头
所以就是对我的耳朵蛮好的
那我又希望这些细节能够让大家听到
但我又不是属于大赏型的
所以我其实必须要很了解麦克风跟我的配合
然后来尽量去能够完整的呈现我想要唱的东西
给大家人脉合一这个状态
人脉合一对人脉合一
♪ 记得了你还有哪些一言为定 ♪
♪ 现在我知道我始终确信 ♪
♪ 虽然我不不到你 ♪
很多团队的小伙伴都说
哎您的团队是一个自己给自己找麻烦的团队
的确是会一个自己给自己找麻烦
但又乐在其中的团队
2.0
严格来说已经算是3.0
我们等于经历了三次的进化
每一个工作人员对自己自身都有要求之后
我们有一个蛮龟毛的导演哦
很开心
当有一个人对自己这么严格的时候
终于可以放心的好好的教给他
觉得他在台上看起来就是很甜美
很轻松
很自在
但是看过她私底下在工作上的样子
其实大概就知道他的他在意的点是什么
他也是我第一个看过
就是呃在排练教室舞蹈
他是拿歌词一个一个笔记
就是觉得他在需要他表现的地方
他很认真
因为心灵他是一直很在意呃
演出的内容
带领的人都是这样子的时候
其实底下的人也会整体都是这样子
所以你会感受得到我们的向心力
应该这么说
应该说它就是那一颗主要的糖
而我们呢就是可能就是那些奶油包裹着它
让它成为这一个大蛋糕
我们如果可以很真诚的在台上展现热情
给观众很真诚的笑
观众一定会给我们相对的回应
都说呀在王心凌SUGHAI2.0的舞台
每个像素呢都是对抗时间的武器
我其实呢在2004年啊
还在听WALKMAN的时代
就开始听王心凌的歌了
记忆中的那条老街呢似乎还在播放
第一次爱的人
那个时候啊
我甚至连CD机都买不起啊
不过还是买了很多王心凌的专辑
并且呢把海报贴在了老家的墙上
陈老师我准备了两张专辑的
帮忙签个名吧
对这个是这个是爱你的这一张专辑
对这是我收藏的一张
呵呵对啊是吧
这是改版的哈
哎我跟你讲啊
当初哦在台北的寒流
所以天气非常非常非常非常的冷
然后呢呃当时我就跟当时的计划姐姐
我们在看照片的时候
然后他们就确定选了这张
这样子要当这个封面
然后我说姐姐我我的鼻头这边有一滴鼻水啊
哈哈把那鼻水修掉的
这个真的这个很复古
这这个很值得纪念
这个对跨越了20年对
然后这个专辑都变了
王鑫老师一点都没有变哇
哦我这今天听到很开心的一句话
跨越20年的今天
曾经买的那张爱你的专辑呀
包装盒呢都已经经过了岁月的洗礼
但近距离啊看到咱们的甜心天后呢
和记忆中似乎没有什么区别
还是那么的元气
能量满满
也许热爱呀真的可以让时间停滞
青春不朽
喜欢王心凌老师多久很久了吧
从读书开始是我们的青春
现在有20年
十几年了
十几年了哦
12年十年三年级到现在工作第8年了
已经有十多年了
她刚出道的时候就是会经常看他电视剧
然后会听他的歌呃
小学那个微笑pasta的时候
从微笑pasta就很喜欢他了
Pasta easy easy
笑一笑
♪ 没什么大不了了 ♪
Easy ea
♪ 一起一起唱吧 ♪
♪ 唱唱唱 ♪
♪ 天空是绵绵的糖 ♪
♪ 就算塌下来又怎样 ♪
♪ 深呼吸 ♪
♪ 甩开悲伤 ♪
♪ 深情唱棒 ♪
♪ 就大声唱 ♪
因为DV其实比起画质
它更多讲究的是一个感觉
氛围对就好
打开时光机的感觉
那我今天在拍的时候
那个感觉像是怎么说呢
我在拍20年前MTTV频道的演唱会
纪实大又怎样
♪ 干脆开始的第一char ♪
可爱啊
继续打
结婚好不好
就大家会看他的表演
不自觉会嘴角上扬
就是可能他会带有一点灰
所以我就觉得这个是他的魔法
看到他的舞台
你就会感觉到一种很幸福的感觉
有一种很温暖的力量在支撑自己
唱功好
人品好
反正各方面都很好
其实我觉得他的歌都很有很有能量
对于我来说
她是我的有精神支柱
优美又帅
又能唱又能演
在我心目中
她是一个非常压台的艺人
要求完美的美女
谁可以比他甜呐
啊哈哈哈哈哈
可甜可咸可辣可爱
教主啊
对甜度爆表的教对对对吧
♪ 小吉祥后转身在山中多有烦恼 ♪
♪ 谁都在回过再多 ♪
♪ 一生很好 ♪
♪ 代餐好身体 ♪
♪ 换上快乐舞 ♪
♪ 哎善良的朋友来吧 ♪
嘿嘿嘿
♪ 有话要直说 ♪
♪ 别让机会又擦肩溜走 ♪
有这么美的老板
就是上班
看起来就是笑嘻嘻的上班
你知道其实很累了之后看到哇好可以
可以继续有动力上班
觉得他非常聪明
非常聪明
然后被好多
比如说呃舞蹈方面的东西
他都学的很快
然后记忆也很好
在编导的过程中
他给了我很多启发
嗯就是觉得心灵姐姐好漂亮
很专业
就是对很多小细节都很认真对待
这样子让我们也会想要很认真
把舞台就是做得更完美
随时随地看到她都像仙女一样
那老师这么多年跟心灵合作
您感觉最大的一个印象是什么呢
这个艺人很啊自律
在私底下跟工作人员也是呃完成一片
再加上他本人对就是非常敬业
而且也很专业啊
所以在整个前置制作演唱会的过程当中
就是真的蛮享受的
然后也最后呈现出来的结果大家也非常的满意
我刚才采访您团队的每一个人
对您的评价其实都不太一样
有评价您比较甜
比较辣
比较酷
然后很多很多
那么我特别想问您
用一个词或者一句话来形容自己
你会选择用哪个词或者哪句话
我觉得现在的我就是享受享受享受
因为我觉得我现在很享受舞台
我也很享受生活嗯
享受当下
就是我是真的是热爱这个舞台跟唱歌对
就是希望把这个欢乐带给他们
在这两个半钟头
也希望他们可以忘却一切
你知道吗
我好像有看到歌迷讲说类似
就是排到这个演唱会
好像就是他来到了一个小乌托邦
就他可以忘忘却所有的烦恼
在这两个半小时
那他可以在这里找到一些力量
在这边可以忘记所有的不开心
那作为总导演来说
您想对来看新年演唱会的观众说一些什么话
进到这个国度
我觉得就好好享受它
就是你可以拿出你一个
就是你平时没办法散发出来的童心
享受他的舞台吧
真的很棒
非常厉害
就好好的享受
看这一场的秀
你会甜度满分
看得开心
这个演唱会非常的精彩
如果你不来看的话
是你毕生的遗憾啊
我能拍到的其实就是大部分观众来这儿
你看你们也能拍到的东西
其实就是我们有一个善善于观察
善于发现的眼睛就行了
它的设计已经足够美了
你从哪个角度看
其实都是漂亮的
只是你可以在不同角度欣赏不同的美而已
看
但是拍的过程我觉得可以把手机拿下来
用眼睛自己的眼睛去真实的去看
比你手机录下来
回去再看那个重播
我觉得现场感受都会可以来两场吗
好拍一场看一场啊
对对哎
这个可以
欢迎来到sugar land
2.0啊
我是乐队总监芬达啊
我同时也担任键盘手
希望你们在这个音乐盛宴里面
可以感到笔的自在
然后可以感到非常多的甜啊
希望我们大家都能够珍惜我们每一次的相见
珍惜我们每一次的相伴
欢迎你们来到
生还200的糖果世界
Oh baby
♪ 情话多说一点 ♪
♪ 想我就多看你一眼 ♪
♪ 表现多一点点 ♪
♪ 让我能真的看见 ♪
♪ Oh bye ♪
♪ 少说一点 ♪
♪ 想陪你 ♪
♪ 不只一天多一点 ♪
♪ 让我心甘情愿爱你 ♪
就今天的话呢
不光我们是拍摄
我们这个非常美丽的这个王心凌老师
然后包括我们也采访了很多
这个场内的这个舞者啊
然后工作人员大家所有人的一个双向奔赴
双向奔赴哈
然后呢
小明老师也用这台机器
帮我们拍了很多幕后的素材啊
包括很多粉丝的一个采访
这个还是蛮有意义的
第几次来看王心凌老师演唱会
第四次
第九次了
第五次
今天是第第三次
第几次来看这个演唱
第一次
所以我非常激动
第四次了
第第九次感受就是啊
从小到大追的偶像没有白追他
很他的这个精神以及嗯很值得我们学习
是一个很励志的偶像
刺激甜
我好爱超爱
极其爱我
只能说它是完美的存在
姐姐我会永远爱你
王心凌
我们爱你
我来还广州
非常爱你
嘿嘿王心凌永远会支持你
希望你返场哦
祝你天天开心
我希望能成为他她一样的大明星
加油心凌姐姐王心凌
希望你永远健康
永远的跳下去
我们永远爱你
希望王姐能够一直健健康康
开开心心幸福的生活下去
然后也一直继续的发歌
发专辑给我们粉丝听
我们永远都会站在你背后去支持你的
我喜欢你很多年了
然后我带了很多王大龙来
这个是佛山版的
然后这个是京剧版的
那希望你开完2.0之后呢
可以休息
然后给我们带来更好的3.0
4.0或者新专辑
谢谢爱他一辈子
呵呵希望她越来越好
越来越幸福
就这个状态一直保持下去吧
王心凌爱你
谢谢大家
今天花了一点时间来到了这里
看我们的演出
希望今天晚上能让大家带着满满的爱回家
谢谢我右手边的你们
♪ 后面的你们 ♪
♪ 谢谢 ♪
你用广州的大家有个甜甜的梦
愿星星陪伴着你们入睡
晚安啦
亲爱的早宗
♪ 谢谢广州 ♪
♪ 谢谢 ♪
♪ 辛苦啦拜拜辛苦啦 ♪
虽然说今天呢我们又使用了red电影机
又使用了DV
使用了智能眼镜
又有手机
其实一场演唱会的成功举办
真的是成百上千个细节堆砌而成的
一个非常庞大的工程
才能让这场演唱会啊更为成功的举办开来
所以说呢这么多设备
这么多器材都不是重要的
也许你只有一部手机也可以记录这么多热爱
只是我们今天非常有幸啊
能得到王心凌团队的一个认可啊
可以深入到后台啊
前台的各个细节
各个位置啊
去了解大家共同的一个热爱
那除了王心凌老师事无巨细
亲力亲为
那还有这么多幕后人员一起撑起的
这个SU根烂的哈
大家来到这里之后才会感觉非常的开心
来到这里
也能享受到整个舞台来带来的一些感受
那如果喜欢这期视频的话
还是那句话
别忘了一键三连
我们下期再见
拜拜